hi my name is ashley zachary and i am a
senior biology major from colorado
springs colorado
and tonight is my honor to introduce mr
charles learson
charles learson is a journalist author
and adjunct professor at the city
university of new york's graduate school
of journalism
mr learson has been an editor for sports
illustrated people and us weekly and
spent 11 years at newsweek where he was
a senior writer covering sports
entertainment family and breaking news a
recipient of the national mental health
associate association's media award mr
lear zinn has written for sports
illustrated esquire rolling stone the
new york times magazine smithsonian
money
people tv guide and 17. he is the author
of several books including crazy good
the true story of dan patch the most
famous horse in america
blood and smoke a true tale of mystery
mayhem and the birth of the indy 500 and
most recently ty cobb a terrible beauty
which won the 2015 casey award for the
best baseball book of the year
please join me in welcoming mr lyrizing
good evening and thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be here
lovely introduction
uh just to satisfy my curiosity is
how many people
have seen this picture before
a lot right
okay
questions get harder
there was no wrong answer to that one
right
who's the catcher anyone though
no
no
right arrow good i mean you're a little
that's a little late
year's 1912 it's frozen and frozen
moment from 1912 it's kind of cool isn't
it
no
his name is paul critchell he later
became a yankee scout and he disguised
that discovered lou gehrig actually
gehrig was nine years old when this
picture was taken
somewhere in new york but this is in i
think it's in st louis
uh because it's the saint louis browns
and that's my friend
the airborne man
and uh from this you can also uh
you can you can you can win a bar bet
you know what was ty cobb's number right
we'll get back to this
all goal is divided into three parts
julius caesar said
raw wrote
and i had the same impression of america
about five years ago
when i started to write a book about a
long dead baseball player named tyrus
raymond cobb
there seemed to be three distinct
schools of thought on my subject
or maybe i should say two schools in one
non-school
let's start with that latter confusing
group
after asking around a bit in my
neighborhood in brooklyn new york and
conducting a highly un scientific poll
of friends and relatives and
acquaintances scattered about the globe
i came to the conclusion that there were
an awful lot of people who had no
thoughts or opinion about ty cobb one
way or the other and for a very good
reason
they had no idea who he was
an athlete a few in this group guessed
rather feebly but just as many thought
he was the guy who invented the cop
salad
and most of the people just hated me for
asking them a question they didn't know
the answer to
or they hated me more than they had
before
this the reaction this ignorance
frightened me
i mean
it's in a shiver down my spine into my
wallet
i mean i do this for a living
and think about it before too long i
would be out there peddling a book
promising to tell you everything you
wanted to know about someone you
probably never heard of
this is not a recipe for success
so that was the first school of thought
or
non-school of thought or school of
non-thought and to me it was a
distressingly large one but it wasn't
the biggest
you know the biggest group by far i
sense consisted of people who had who
had very definitely had heard of ty cobb
but who thought of him in negative terms
not just as a sour puss or even a
serious misanthrope but as one of the
worst human beings who ever lived
to them he was an undeniably great
player a king of the so-called dead ball
era i should say here that tycho played
in the major leagues from 1905 to 1928
all but two of those years for the
detroit tigers
and he was a superstar
the first man voted into the hall of
fame
his lifetime batting average 366 over 23
and a half seasons is amazing
and still the highest of all time
these people in the second group knew
all that but they would tell you that
cobb for all his talent was a racist
bastard and a mean spike sharpening son
of a [ __ ] i sound like kurt chilling
now don't
who thought nothing of injuring his
fellow players just to gain another base
or score a run
everyone hated him the members of this
group would say indeed quite a few
people i encountered early and even late
in my research process described cobb as
a murderer
some braided together the racist and
murderer motifs and asked if i was going
to write about the time cobbs stay
stabbed to death a black waiter in
cleveland just because the young man was
acting uppity
ron shelton the director of the 1995
movie cobb told me it was well known
that cobb had killed as many as three
people
but whatever the variation of the story
they subscribe to whatever crimes and
misdemeanors they put in and left out of
their tail the people in this group
fervently believed the basic theme of
evil and it was easy to see why they've
been told that cobb was a bad man over
and over all of their lives the sheer
repetition was impressive to them
the repetition
felt like evidence
and they were told over and over about
cobb's depravity by people they
respected told very often by their
daddies who passed down to them all the
sacred baseball war the things you
needed to know to be a well-rounded
person in the world
they also read about the bad cob and
articles and books in one such book
written by a man named al stump
it was said that when little children
wrote to cobb asking for an autographed
picture of baseball advice he steamed
the penny stamps off the return
envelopes and kept them for himself and
never wrote back
in another book this one about ty cobb's
contemporary tris speaker a respected
baseball historian named timothy gay
wrote that ty cobb could not abide the
sight of a black person walking down the
street
gay said that he
would pistol whip any african-american
he saw on the sidewalk
then of course there were the stories
about how ty cobb sharpened his spikes
before every game cobb that was written
in several books and many articles would
sit in the dugout sometimes it was set
on top of the dugout honing his cleats
with a large file and cackling
maniacally
and of course many people also saw the
myth of the evil cobb reiterated and
certified at the movies which after all
reach many more people than books do
in films like 1995's cobb with tommy lee
jones which was based on a book written
by al stump who made a career out of
painting cobb as a monster
and before that in the movie field of
dreams in that beloved 1989 film the
shoeless joe jackson character says that
cobb wasn't invited to the ghostly
cornfield reunion of the old-time ball
players because quote no one liked that
son of a [ __ ]
it's a famous line that always seems to
get a laugh
and and not just when you're watching
the movie people enjoy quoting it in
conversation and chuckling over it over
and over again
it's a safe way of establishing common
ground with someone we know our baseball
don't we and it made people feel good
about themselves and superior to this
morally corrupt character named ty cobb
we should note well the love of that
line
and the laughter it caused because those
things tell us something important about
the myth of the evil thai cobb
namely that people loved it and found it
entertaining
since the myth came into being in 1961
after cobb's death more on that in a
minute
they have trotted it out and buffed it
up and improved upon it tricking it out
with creative details of their own
invention as happens in a game of
telephone
thus does a scuffle with a white hotel
night watchman evolve into the final
fatal stabbing of a black waiter
thus does one fake death become three
as i stand here someone is probably
retelling the tale on the internet and
the waiter who never existed has become
the devoted father of infant twins and a
rhodes scholar
the tall tales lives and breathes and
endures
indeed though it deals with ugly
behavior by a despicable and repulsive
man
the story of the evil tycob is one of
the most beloved myths in all of
baseball
so that was the second group the people
who knew cobb was a ball player and
thought he was just awful
and that group was large and vocal and
quite confident
zealous in their beliefs eager
to proselytize
the third group by contrast was small in
size and uncertain
these were the people who had heard of
the evil cobb and who were perhaps
impressed by the popularity of the myth
but also had annoying doubt about it
the evil tie cop to these people was a
little too bad to be true could anyone
possibly be that one-dimensional how
could cobb or anyone always be acting
out the same few character traits in
this case bigotry and unsportsmanlike
conduct in the extreme
24 7 for 70-something years
i mean the kind of individuals who could
be found acting out the same one or two
character traits every time you checked
in on them had names like bugs bunny and
daffy duck
how could a flesh and blood human being
spend more than two decades in the major
leagues traveling from detroit to new
york to chicago to st louis pistol
whipping every african-american person
he saw
or even if that was an exaggeration how
could he go through life in a constant
state of rage set at full boil
to the skeptics in the third category
the evil cop didn't jive with human
experience
the real tyrus raymond cobb couldn't be
that guy they believe because there was
no such guy
but without an alternative narrative to
substitute for the two pat myth
they couldn't say much more
so the third category consisted of you
might say the questioners the thinkers
the smart people
i was not a member of that group
no not at first anyway
no i was squarely with the majority the
evil cobb folks when i started out
and for the same reasons i've been
hearing that story all my life and it
was a great story thrill-packed yarn
that sparked the there but for fortune
feeling in me
i pitched a book about the evil cob to
simon and schuster and they said yes
because guess what the editors there
knew and embraced the myth too
i figured that my task would be
relatively easy i'm a good reporter i
thought and so i will go out go back to
the original source material the
newspaper accounts documents letters
things that previous biographers had not
looked too hard at
find fresh examples of ty cobb being
monstrous
blend that stuff with the al the stuff
that al stump and others had written and
voila i i'd have a book the first
tyco book in more than 20 years
the first thing i did actually while i
was still working on the proposal was to
read several of the previous biographies
then i got on a plane and went from new
york city to royston the town in the
northern hills of georgia where cobb had
grown up and where he is buried
i walked the streets i stood on the spot
where his boy at home had been
i visited his crypt
cobb had built a family final resting
place shortly before he died in 1961.
it's the centerpiece of the local
cemetery and attracts a steady trickle
of tourists there was a weathered pine
reef wreath a plastic pink lily and a
few baseballs stuck behind the grating
in front of the door how pathetic i
thought
scene fit for a villain
i pressed my forehead on the warm glass
window and peered inside
peered inside
cobb and spencer's sister were on one
side
and their parents were on the other very
tidy i thought just as you might expect
though i would have thought the same
thing if it had been messy in there
i had predisposition towards believing
cobb was evil remember and so whatever i
saw would have confirmed my opinion
you know how they say that your hair and
your fingernails continue to grow after
you die
as i slit squinting through that window
i imagined cobb lying there in a kind of
howard yuzion de chabil his fingers and
his hair and his fingernails filling the
casket like excelsior
the shrinking flesh pulling back his
mouth into a hideous zombie grin
i was scaring myself a bit creating a
little horror movie in my head
and it was fun
then i came back to new york and i
started to do the kind of nuts and bolts
research the kind of going back to the
original sources and such that any
experienced professional writer does but
which as i say had never been done very
very thoroughly with cobb why not
well for one thing there have been
relatively few attempts to compose a
life of cobb for all of his fame but
perhaps because of his reputation there
had only been three or four full-scale
books on him when i came along so not
many people had even put themselves in a
position to to do serious cobb research
but beyond that baseball history books
just don't have the same standards as
say books about the roman empire or the
civil war
baseball books are offered written by
hungover sports writers sitting at their
desk and remembering things
they sometimes don't cite sources at all
or they source something to a previous
baseball book which probably didn't have
a source
i guess the feeling is it's only
baseball after all it doesn't really
matter
of course one upshot of this is that a
baseball rider can get away with murder
it is more difficult and expensive to
find and collect long-buried information
and it sometimes leads to the discovery
of inconvenient truths
so why would i want to do it well in my
case and i hope this doesn't sound like
a humble brag but doing good
old-fashioned nuts and bolts research or
sometimes it's called shoe weather
reporting was really the only way i knew
how to proceed i learned how to be a
journalist at newsweek and its heyday
and i later worked as an executive
editor at sports illustrated and wrote
stories for the sunday new york times
magazine and such i was used to working
alongside some very scrupulous writers
and dealing with aggressive fact
checkers i'd also survived writing a
book with donald trump so difficult
assignments were you might say in my
comfort zone
a minute ago i mentioned inconvenient
truths
the thing you might find in the course
of your research that contradict your
preconceived notions of some aspect of
your subject matter and are often
difficult to explain
some writers dislike such things and
hope to never find one and if they do
sometimes pretend they didn't
but i had the most unusual experience
researching this book
i discovered a fairly whopping
inconvenient truth oh about 10 minutes
into my research on cobb
i was doing a search of articles in the
atlanta journal constitution because
cobb is from georgia and i came across a
curious piece written in late 1911 after
the baseball season when cobb was
touring in a play a three-act comedy
called the college widow in those days
when ball players were tied to their
teams by means of something called the
reserve clause and could never become
free agents and sell their services at
their true market value and therefore
were often making less than the people
watching them in the stands they often
capitalized on their fame in the off
season by appearing in plays or in
vaudeville
cobb was not an especially good actor
but it became immediately apparent to me
as i read the story in the atlanta
constitution which was an account of a
backstage visit with him that he it
worried him that he wasn't a very good
actor because he wanted very much to
please the audience
he also was going out of his way to
accommodate the writer of the piece who
was asking some very stupid and tedious
questions and he was also very
hospitable to a guest an old catcher
friend of his from the minor leagues who
showed up smoking a big cigar and
crayons crammed himself into cobb's
little dressing room along with a
reporter it was like a night at the
opera with the marx brothers with
everyone jammed into that little
stateroom
meanwhile the play the college widow was
in progress and cobb was desperately
trying to make costume changes without
offending his rather thoughtless
visitors while the stage manager was
barking that cobb needed to be on his
mark in 30 seconds
i was really brought up short by this
little story a scene that i wound up
using to lead off the book
the account wasn't terribly well written
but it was like a raw security camera
footage of what was going on in that
dressing room in atlanta one saturday
night more than a hundred years ago
and to me it said so much about cobb
really you might say
he was just doing what any decent person
would do under those admittedly strange
circumstances that is being
accommodating and polite to a friend and
an acquaintance kind of smiling his way
through an uncomfortable situation as
best he could perhaps you see where i'm
going with this cobb's sanes and
politeness was exactly the point i had
an effect dropped in on him at a random
moment and found him looking very much
like a normal human being
he worried about what other people
thought
he had a friend
with one story with that one story from
me the myth of the evil cob began to
crack and crumble
i plunged ahead with my research and
soon realized there were more
inconvenient truths than convenient ones
here was an old newspaper clipping
saying that the chicago white sox were
presenting cobb with an award a set of
books actually cobb was known as a
voracious reader
for being the most popular out of town
player hmm
when the tigers were in town ring lard
nurse chicago's smartest and best sports
writer bought cheap seats in the
outfield so we could spend the game
bantering with cobb
here too was a story about cobb's tiger
teammates rushing out on the field to
save him from a rowdy mob of fans the
players swinging their bats like swords
until they got caught to safety
and did he really steal stamps from
little children
letters in museums and private
collections showed that cobb did in fact
respond to his young fans sometimes with
handwritten letters that ran to five
pages he would often apologize for
sending two or three autographed photos
when the writer had asked only for one
and he only told the kids and he always
told the kids at adults who wrote to him
that he was honored by their request for
his autograph
what about the subject of race
many people will tell you that cobb was
an avowed racist
but when and where did he make such a
vow and where is it recorded where is
the evidence carpet is true was born in
georgia in 1886 and a 1984 biography of
cobb written by a college professor
named charles alexander does describe a
hotel night watchman a bellhop and a
butcher that cobb fought with as being
black
these things are enough for the people
who want to believe cobb was a racist
maniac it was certainly enough for the
filmmaker ken burns who in his
documentary baseball described cobb as
an embarrassment to the game because of
his attitudes towards african americans
burns made cobb a central figure in his
film if you remember
casting him as the anti-jackie robinson
but burns did what so many others did he
forgot about the facts which had to be
dug for and went with the low-hanging
assumptions
when i looked into the historical record
census reports birth certificates and
contemporary newspaper accounts i found
that those three men cited by charles
alexander as cobb's opponents were in
fact
white
yes he had fought with a couple of black
people in his day but those tussles
didn't seem to have racial overtones and
cobb with an extremely thin skin for
with many more white men
how did such a distinguished author make
such big mistakes
when i asked alexander how and why he
distorted the record to make cobb look
more like a bigot all he said was
i went with the best information i had
at the time
but it was bad information and it became
an enduring part of the myth
but what about that
cobb's 19th century southern roots
how could someone born in georgia in
1886
not be kind of racist
i'll tell you what i found out not
because i'm a genius or the babe ruth of
researchers but because i used the
methods and standards that would apply
to any conventional history book
ty cobb it turned out descended from a
long line of abolitionists
his great grandfather was a minister who
preached against slavery and was run out
of town for his troubles
his grandfather was the equivalent of a
conscientious objector who refused to
fight in the confederate army because of
the slavery issue and his father was an
educator and state senator who spoke out
for his black constituents and had a
very short political career as a result
and once broke up a lynch mob in town
god himself was never asked about racism
and segregation until 1952 when the
texas league was finally integrating and
the sporting news asked him what he
thought
the negro should be accepted
wholeheartedly and not grudgingly he
said the negro has the right to play
professional baseball and who's to say
he has not
other ball players and ex-ball players
were keeping mum on the topic or saying
they didn't think mixed-race baseball
was a good idea
cob though southern was saying accepted
wholeheartedly and not grudgingly
by then he'd attended many negro league
games sometimes throwing out the first
ball and often sitting in the dugout
with the players
he said that willie mays was the only
modern-day player he'd pay to see and
that roy campanella another black man
was the player who reminded him most of
himself
cobb was like the rest of us a highly
imperfect being
he was far too quick to take offense
too tolerant of those who did not who
didn't strive for excellence with the
same almost crazy zeal that he did
he did not suffer fools gladly and
thought too many people as fools
he was the first baseball celebrity and
he did not always handle well the
responsibilities that came with that
just invented position
yes he once went into the stands and
repeatedly punched a white man and
fellow southerner who had been heckling
him for more than a year and who turned
out to have less than the full
complement of fingers
it was a huge mistake a black mark
against him that he's still paying for
more than a hundred years later in terms
of his reputation
but the worst racist in baseball history
and embarrassment to the game
i don't think so
let me try to describe how cobb fit into
the game of baseball
to talk about the kind of player he was
his numbers are mind-boggling and is
true but they don't tell half the story
we need to be reminded of this because
there's very little motion picture
footage of cobb
but cobb was very unlike was very likely
the most exciting player of all time
yes he got thousands of hits with his
unusual split hands grip
and that in itself was entertaining
but it's what happened after he got on
base that set him apart
ty cobb getting a walk is more exciting
than babe ruth hitting a home run a
sports writer once said and it was true
with ruth who came along just as the
ball was changing and becoming livelier
and swung for the fences in a way that
cobb didn't
the thrills were electric
but they were over in a flash
when cobb made it to first which he did
more than anyone else he batted over 403
seasons
the fun had just begun
cobb understood the rhythms and the
protocols of the game and he constantly
fooled around with them keeping everyone
nervous and off balance he played with
the sports writers then called
psychological baseball though he often
appeared to be in need of a psych ward
himself
his stated intention was to be a mental
hazard for the opposition and he did
this by hopping around in the batter's
box constantly changing his stance as
the pitcher released the ball and then
when he got on base hopping around some
more chattering making false starts
limping around and feigning injury and
running at precisely the wrong moment
when you'd least expect it
he still holds the record for stealing
home perhaps the most exciting play in
all of baseball and rarely seen today
he did it 54 times
think about it
ty cobb once stole second third and home
on three consecutive pitches
he once turned to tap back to the
pitcher's mound into an inside the park
home run
and he didn't even slide
on several occasions he caused an
exasperating opposing infielder to toss
his glove into the air or slam it to the
ground in frustration and then get
tossed for the game out of the game for
doing so
the greatness of ty cobb is something
that had to be seen george sisler said
and to see him was to remember him
forever
god was not a natural he often insisted
the way shoes joe jackson was he worked
hard to turn himself into a ballplayer
and everything he did on the field
though it may have looked helter skelter
as he liked to say and seen contrary to
the textbook was a considered decision
he had nine styles of slides in his
repertoire the hook the fade away the
straight ahead the short slide the head
first the chicago slide the first base
slide the home plate slide even one
called the cuttlefish slide so named
because he purposely sprayed dirt with
his spikes the way that cunning
squid-like creature squirts ink
coming in he would always watch the
infielder's eyes to see what side of the
bag the ball was headed toward and then
tried to slide the other way
a lot of his energy went into avoiding
contact because contact could of course
make him an easier person to tag
at the same time he believed very
strongly that the runner had the right
of way in what he called my little patch
right in front of the bag if the fielder
wanted to put his leg or his hands in
that dangerous zone that was as they
said on in those days on his watch
the other players i found respected
cobb's ability and his consistency and
agreed with the little patch theory
it was no fun putting the ball on cobb
when he came slashing into the plate
said wally shang an american league
catcher but he never cut me up he was
too pretty a slider to hurt anyone who
put the ball on him right
cop's teammate infielder germany shaffer
said ty cobb is a game square fellow who
never cut a man with the spikes
intentionally in his life and anyone who
gets by with his spikes knows it
the general theme of the ballplayer
appraisals was that the civilians may
think that cobb uses his spikes too much
but we the men who play the game
know better
and if cobb could dish out the
punishment and the intimidation he could
also take it steve o'neill of the
cleveland knaps once favored cobb with
the greatest compliment a catcher can
give
he came home on a base hit and was
blocking the plate
and i was blocking the plate o'neil said
i got him in the kidneys and knocked him
out
when he came to he didn't say a word he
just got up and limped back to his
position
it's interesting what happens sometimes
when you put aside long-held assumptions
and look at facts
this behind me is a famous photograph
that is often used to indict cobb
it shows cobb and st louis
brown's catcher paul critchell in 1912.
sometimes on social media when i'm
describing what my book is about wise
guys will respond by sending me this it
will sometimes arrive with no
explanation the message being that no
explanation is needed it says a thousand
words about cobbs being a spike's crazy
fiend
in this photo cobb appears to be flying
foot first into kritchel's crotch while
the catcher squints like the just shot
lee harvey oswald
if you spend some time in the library
though you will find a 1950s interview
with critchel about this incident and by
critch's own testimony the image is
deceiving
it turns out that the only ball cobb was
aiming for was the one in krital's hand
and he struck it with precision and
knocked it all the way to the backstop
here's what critchell said about the
incident in the 1950s when he was a
scout for the yankees
cobb came tearing into me when you talk
about explosions that was one the ball
hit the grandstand on the fly i was mad
and stunned cobb was mad and shaken in a
way it was really my fault
i was standing in front of the plate
instead of on the side where i could
tie as he slid by but out of that mix-up
i learned one thing never stand directly
in front of the plate when cobb is
roaring for home
if you did it was at your own risk
so how did we get from here from the
real thai cobb was always trying to be a
mental hazard and was controversial as a
result
to
ty khan was one of the worst human
beings who ever lived
well the myth of the evil cop does have
some seeds in his playing career
no one called him a racist when he was
still alive because for one thing the
word did not exist until after his death
but people in those days were fascinated
by spikes to a great degree i think
because they had no personal experience
with them
an adult fan and say 1910 had almost
certainly not played scholastic baseball
or little league and so we thought of
spikes as something exotic something
both medieval and out of jewels vern
i found newspaper articles predicting
that players would eventually be killed
by one another's spikes if safety
measures were not immediately taken
it made no sense a bat and a ball are
really more deadly
i also found that the legend of the man
who sharpened his spikes had been
floating around since at least the 1880s
and had been attributed to many players
including hall of famer john mcgraw
but some sports writers especially those
outside of detroit were willing to fan
that flame and depict the aggressive
unpredictable cop as a dirty player they
understood even that early in the
history of professional sports that
sports is not so much about scores as it
is about story lines
and that without antagonists
stories fall flat
many of the quotes i found from rivals
defending cobb's running style were in
response to charges that he was a spiker
to a man they said he wasn't and cobb
actually wrote the american league
president in 1910 asking that players be
forced to dull their spikes with a file
so they so he might finally be free of
the dirty player charge
but the story was too appealing
the idea of a jack the ripper in
baseball flannels too titillating to go
away
so cobb was always controversial
as anyone trying to be a mental hazard
will be
yet the question remains how did he
become
a monster
it was a perfect storm of conditions
that made this happen but one factor i
believe involves the simple passage of
time ty cobb was fading from memory even
in his own lifetime after he retired in
1928 he stayed out of major league
baseball as the game changed to a
slugger sport it became the game of ted
williams and joe dimaggio and mickey
mantle and cobb became increasingly
irrelevant a museum piece a trivia
answer
when cobb went on the tv quiz show i've
got a secret in the late 50s the
panelists not only didn't guess his
secret i have the highest batting
average of all time they didn't know who
he was
cobb as an old man didn't like not being
recognized but he hated even more that
when he was remembered it was as a dirty
player who sharpened his spikes and slid
too hard
he wanted people to appreciate his game
as he became older and got sicker cobb
somewhat became somewhat obsessed with
setting the record straight and he
started to shop around an autobiography
double day and company agreed to publish
it for a very very modest advance and
assigned a ghostwriter because cobb was
obviously too ill to do it himself
for this job they picked a man who was
known for quantity over quality
a hard-drinking hack newspaper man named
al stump
stump who never met cobb before spent a
few days with him then pulled together a
few old magazine articles and went off
to write
for several months he refused to show
cobb the work in progress even though it
was cobb's own autobiography
when cobb finally prevailed upon the
publisher and did get a look he was
extremely upset stump was filling the
gaps by making his up stories his
stories right out of b movies cobb's
voice in the book sounded suspiciously
like a hard drinking newspaper hack and
they were embarrassing errors on
practically every page cobb and letters
threatened the lawsuit if the book
wasn't cancelled or completely rewritten
then he died and the book my life in
baseball the true record came out a few
months later sales were lukewarm at best
and it looked like he would that would
be that cobb would go back to being
forgotten
but then soon afterwards the always
enterprising stump struck a deal with a
sensationalistic unfact-checked
barbershop museum ironically named true
for four thousand dollars a tidy sum in
1961 and a thousand dollars more than he
got for the ghost writing gig with cobb
he would write a see me tell all that
what it was like to live and work with
cobb in those final days
had negotiated the big fee by promising
the tale of a wild man drinking to
excess and driving around lake tahoe
waving a gun at unnamed people cursing
at
uh unnamed emergency room doctors
flinging drinks at unnamed bartenders
and waking up an unnamed backpack bank
president in the middle of the night in
person with a gun to stop a five dollar
check
all the women in cops family feared him
stump said again without naming names to
men and women alike he was a bully in
the extreme and yes he may have killed
some unnamed person that was never
prosecuted in the story never made the
newspapers
everyone in baseball hated him and only
three people from baseball had come to
his funeral stump said
it didn't matter that many sports
writers rushed to cobb's defense saying
that they had visited him at his homes
in tahoe and georgia during the same
period and spent more time with him than
stump had in fact
and they'd never witnessed anything like
that kind of behavior it didn't matter
that all of stump sources were anonymous
all of his quotes blind and that stumps
himself had been banned from several
major newspapers and magazines for
writing fiction
it didn't matter that cobb's family had
put out the word that the funeral was a
private service and asked outsiders not
to come but that thousands of local
people packed the church and lined the
way to the cemetery anyway
people thrilled to the story of the
monstrous out of control ultimately
hated figure the story got so much
attention because no one had ever seen
anything like this before
written about a once famous ball player
this was remembered nine years before
before jim bowden's landmark book ball
four the first to show that baseball
players drink curse pop pills and chase
skirts
the story which was delicious in itself
and seemed to dovetail neatly with carb
being a wild man on the base paths
became a sensation and he took on a life
of its own with people adding details as
they as they retold it
if gob seemed unlike other men in his
extreme wretchedness that was because
well he came from back there in the
misty past where baseball and people
were different right and of course he
was not around to defend himself
the next big development on the cob
front came in 1984 when charles
alexander publishes whoppers about cobb
fighting with all sorts of black people
the civil rights movement had happened
in the interim the word racist was now
very much a part of the lexicon and
people were eager to make assumptions
about a southern white man
it wasn't just a perfect storm it was a
very long one a decade later in the
early 90s director ron shelton brought
the screen right to stump's true
magazine article and urged them to write
another book a biography as opposed to
an autobiography that would expand on
the article and which might both help
promote the movie and and benefit from
it as well shelton wanted to make stumps
a 1994 book uh
oh i'm sorry subs 1994 book became a
huge bestseller the the biography and it
was excerpted in sports illustrated and
despite the fact that it was based it
was basically a rewrite of stump's
original article and a rewrite of
alexander's book with a bunch of new
cheesy b-movie scenes thrown in to fill
out the pages
then came ken burns baseball documentary
which rehashed stumped in alexander's
ideas for a new generation and off we
went
the internet got
uh the internet goose the game of the
telephone to hyperspeed
just search for tycob on twitter and see
what you find
al stump was not a good writer but
either
understood or stumbled upon the fact
that if you give people something they
want to believe they will take it and
run with it and make it their own
after all who doesn't like a monster
story especially one that allows the
teller to express his own superiority to
say
i'm not a slave to feelings of racism
and anger like this pathetic man was i
look down upon that kind of behavior
a scary story that is also a feel-good
story is hard to beat
but i knew that going into this project
i was an editor at people magazine and i
understand that humans like to gossip
and wag their finger and take delight in
the fact that the rich and famous are
possibly more miserable than they are
what i didn't understand until i
undertook this project was the power of
repetition to mold minds
in some cases repetition may be stronger
than truth
you know how i said earlier that your
hair and fingernails continue to grow
after your death
that's not true
and the fact that we've heard it a
million times doesn't make it so
in cop's case
people were entertained and flattered by
the myth of evil
that was created by this scandal monger
named al stump so they repeated it and
they became impressed by the sound of
their own echoing voice and that's a
shame
because along the way a man's reputation
was destroyed and a very good story
a reality that is more interesting than
the myth was obliterated
i didn't set out to write any wrongs or
clean up cobb's reputation indeed as
i've told you i originally set out to
soil it some more
but in trying to start from scratch and
tell the story of a man's life i wound
up with a biography that for better or
worse comes with a message at least for
those people in that large and avid
second group
who believe the myth of the evil cob and
the message is simply this
stop talking for a minute and listen
because there's a lot of evidence to the
contrary
has the message been received
is it too late to change the image of ty
cobb
i'm grateful that the book has been well
received and won some prizes and
individual readers write me almost every
day and tell me that it changed their
mind
but at this point it's really too soon
to say anything about the larger issue
to tell if the evidence i present is
more powerful than the drum beat of
repetition or the soothing impression
that there was someone out there worse
than myself
john the evangelist said the truth will
set you free but there is also the
reality of the stockholm syndrome in
which hostages love and cling avidly to
the person or thing that holds them in
bondage
i guess in the end it's me versus al
stump
who will win
it's an interesting question at least to
me and my mother
in terms of cobb's legacy all i know for
certain is that the greatness of ty cobb
was something that had to be seen
and to see it was to remember it
forever
thanks a lot
thank you for bearing with me my ipad
screen went on auto dim there for a
while
mr leerson has agreed to sign copies of
his book ty cobb a terrible beauty
immediately following the session just
outside in the phillips lobby we have
time for a few questions please stand
when the microphone comes to you
um are there any more recent sports
stars such as barry bonds or jose
canseco who have been unfairly painted
as villains in your opinion
well i didn't i couldn't understand you
sorry oh are there any more recent
sports stars such as barry bonds or jose
canseco who in your opinion have been
unfairly painted as villains oh any
other stars
yeah
i found cop's story to be kind of unique
uh
you know i looked for in a way to in a
way that it it makes the argument a
little harder to make to say
who else did this happen to
and i haven't quite found it it's the
right combination of circumstances it
couldn't really happen today
um i don't think because everyone knows
everything out there and you know if
someone's living you could go to them
and talk to them
i mean so to to a degree of course you
may argue that you know
barry bonds was prosecuted too hard for
something he did that wasn't real he
wasn't technically breaking the rules
you can make arguments like that but
with cobb you had to have this thing
where it was first of all baseball so it
didn't matter second of all it was it
was in the distant past
just about beyond the reach not quite
just by the on the reach of the motion
picture camera
and uh and then it had to have this you
would get the selfish thing the
satisfaction
thing to it where it makes me feel good
to tell this story because i'm by
denouncing this person i'm saying
something about myself and you know when
you give people a chance to talk about
themselves in an indirect artful way
flatter themselves it's a pretty it's a
pretty appealing topic i mean someone
told me
uh english
professor that i know that edward allen
edward allen edgar allan poe uh had
suffered from a little bit of the same
thing that he wasn't the crazed drug
addict that we think he was that there
was one bad biography that started that
but this is a a a a fairly you know
it's a unique
there's not degrees of uniqueness
english majors okay so it's a unique
situation and and uh
uh that uh of a snowball
turning into an avalanche you know
yes
well
i know it sounds self-serving but i i
don't get too much of a pushback from
people who've read the book because
everything i say i back up with the
footnote
endnotes and sources
the sources are either in the text or in
the endnotes in the back so
uh if i say something happened or i
assert something i i
you know it's right there and it's kind
of hard to argue with that initially
before people have read it and when i
was first doing publicity for it i got a
lot of pushback because people didn't
want to part with this myth and they
actually thought it was funny are you
going to say ty cobb was a normal human
being you know and uh
just you know within a certain range he
was a very
remarkable human being but he you know
he didn't he had this subject to the
same gravitational forces and emotional
forces that the rest of us are uh and uh
so
i got i get that and i still get that
from people who are just stumbling upon
the book who who don't want and hear the
myth who've who who who don't who don't
want to change their mind don't want to
believe it and think that i'm a i get
called
a revision writing revisionist history
i'm not sure what that means i guess
you know i'm i'm i'm writing history if
it revises what they think i can't help
that you know
do you think tight
tie cobs uh personality his
his temperament was similar to pete rose
and that he did some things that made
him vulnerable to this type of
image
yeah i i don't know how similar they
were exactly but they were tycott was a
very difficult man
and uh probably more difficult than pete
rose although you know i'm just i've
been in pete rose's presence and
i was in the courtroom when he was
sentenced to
his tax evasion charge and i've seen
them in different situations i've been
in clubhouses with them
i haven't been there with ty cobb really
and i haven't had this sense of
sitting there with him talking to him
um they both they're both very intense
they both put a high priority on
baseball and and they don't do anything
halfway you know and so they're gonna
have
and and rose was without articulating it
as well as cobb did also
was about being a mental hazard for the
other team you know so uh
yeah probably the same yeah in some ways
i think ty cobb's a lot more smarter and
more and more refined than pete rose too
yeah oh yeah
thank you for your astonishing writing
and uh elan and your voice in delivering
what you wrote thank you
um
you've written a cautionary tale that in
a complicated political season has a
lesson for us and i won't veer into that
area
you've also said that what happened to
ty cod ty cobb could not happen today
because everybody knows everything but
it does happen
so thank you for your courage in writing
a book that reminds us that we don't
know everything until we really know
somebody
and that everything that we think we
know we should re-examine several times
with a clear conscience and our own
integrity before we make those judgments
thank you very much thank you
first of all is the title from yates
is the title from yates a terrible
beauty yes
uh
okay
as indirect evidence
had cobb been
the dirty fearsome player he has been
portrayed as
since they more or less policed
themselves in that era
would he have had a
24-year career
if if he'd been that bad again don't you
think that somewhere along the line he
would have been policed themselves
well i think if he went around trying to
pistol whip every black person he saw he
wouldn't his career probably about six
months long you know and
hurt beans uh
i mean it's indirect evidence i mean the
baseball players pretty much
we wouldn't be we're talking about him
but yeah uh
uh
you know baseball when he came up it was
changing it's interesting i thought you
know when he came up in 1905
the ball players were kind of like
carnies you know they were they were
they were making a lot less as i say
than the people in the stands they were
there
maybe sort of running away from their
families their fathers never wanted them
to do that
cobb said every baseball biography he
read
the father was against the kid becoming
a ball player in those days and and so
they were these and they drank
they drank their way around the circuit
alcoholism was a bit more people who
were seeing it as a profession and
something that that they
you know will do for life it's not just
a way to kill a few years you know when
you don't have another huge problem uh
in in 1905 by 1910 15 it starts to
change and you uh
uh
they were very rough and tumble crowd in
195 and a very almost anything went you
know guys were would get hauled off the
field because they were drunk and they
were standing on the field uh
uh so
yeah if you if you if you
if he was really that yeah yeah probably
i'd you probably couldn't got away with
it you just couldn't go around sliding
into people and first of all it's not a
good strategy because you you get tagged
out a lot more you know uh the the key
is to be elusive so yeah but there were
guys who were pretty pretty wild and
pretty bad you know
um with tycho being such a contankerous
character in his all his work in
baseball was baseball a positive outlet
for him in the sense that did it help
him to grow and mature as a person and
help him to kind of deal with those
issues or did it not really affect him
in that sense i think it did yeah that's
a good question because i mentioned
briefly in the that he was the first
baseball celebrity you could make a case
for christy matthewson uh contemporary
and uh
in the national league and a pitcher not
an everyday player but uh
we it's it's important to remember when
you talk about any players from this era
the baseball as as we know it now is a
big mass entertainment with two leagues
and a world series
started in 1901 i think you know or
you know right around it was like just a
few years before cobb came up so this
whole thing the whole country was
changing it's one reason i'm fascinated
by this
era in history like between 1885 and
1915 the world changed so much more i
think than it changed in in the last 20
or 30 years even with the with the
advent of the internet and
digitalization i mean so many different
things changed and one thing was mass
entertainment people had more time they
were living in cities now and not on the
on the farm so much and and that they
went to vaudeville and the movies
started the technology there and they
went to
sports they went to baseball games so uh
uh
you know
and you had and so there was this job of
being a baseball celebrity
the players were shocked to learn even
the most basic things had to be figured
out that they would be hierarchies on
teams that somebody would be better than
others and that they would not only get
more money they get more attention and
more adulation and you know the girls
would be crazier about them and all that
this was like new and just being just
being worked out and there was a lot of
resentment about that the protocols and
the etiquette and the ballparks was was
just getting formed and figured out
fans would break that wall and jump over
i mean you know that invisible wall and
jump onto the field and push umpires and
and chase the umpire off the field uh
the week before ty cobb came up in
detroit
fans jumped down in the stands and
chased the empire right out into the
street and he he called it a forfeit for
the you know for the other
favor the other team the players pushed
the umpires the umpire sometimes didn't
throw them out of the game uh because of
that so everyone was working out their
things that so he had to figure out what
it meant to be a celebrity
and and how much he owed the public and
how much how much he didn't know them
and how to act and all this was believe
it or not brand new there were no
role models there were no predecessors
of that
you know 20 years before in 1900 there
were only three sports in america really
there was baseball and it's in its
infancy
boxing and horse racing and and
basketball was was was coming on some
place and you know there were a few
other things but they're very minor very
very much in the background
so you had a he had to figure out what
it meant to be this celebrity and a big
shot
when when the company started coming
after him for endorsements when people
started wanting his time spending time
with him and you know asking him to do
charity events and things like that so i
think he had to figure out
what it meant to be a southern gentleman
in this
in this milieu
thank you for your talk
the first book i ever remember reading
was a book called strange but true
baseball stories it's uh i think it was
written in the 60s and in that book they
talked about how he was discovered and
they told the story about his father
didn't want him to play
and then there was these articles that
started showing up in the paper and i
think after the fact they they found out
that his father was kind of penning the
articles
so i'm interested if that is true and
then second
i believe his his mother had killed his
father right when his career was
starting and i just wondered if you
found
how that impacted him and how that might
have led to some of the
some of the the personality uh i guess
defects that were pointed out by people
yeah well the first part i think is a is
a
his father didn't find out about his
baseball career from the newspapers they
they wrote each other letters they had
they had a good
relationship you know it's a
there's a sort of famous line where his
uh his father says
uh don't come home a failure you know
and that's often used
when you draw this picture of cobb this
southern gothic tale of the mean parents
and the and cobb going off and and it
says like don't don't come home a
failure you know make a lot of money and
bring it home or whatever that would
mean but what really happened was cobb
went off to the minor leagues after
having kind of an argument with his
father's father family said okay wrote a
check for him to go he made the minor
league team he got cut very quickly
found his way
to another minor league team on a lower
level and told his father he was doing
that and his father said good don't come
home it was a very modern attitude like
don't come home now when you're at a low
point and you're always going to
consider yourself a failure try a little
bit more you get cut so fast that's what
it meant so they were in touch a lot and
and i think they had a normal
relationship i mean the word i keep
coming back to
with with cobb is normal and yeah one
thing i meant by the real story is so
much better than the the fake story
where he's turned into a cartoon
character is his mother shot and killed
his father three weeks before he came to
the major leagues and it's still not
clear i present all the evidence and i
get into some new things that no one has
ever written about about the
circumstances it's still not clear
whether that was intentional or not she
was indicted for manslaughter and had to
stand trial
uh which is a traumatic thing in itself
uh just before he went to you know like
i say he was he was doing well and being
scouted and about to go up to the major
leagues and and it was it was three
weeks before that then when he arrived
with the tigers
shortly not too long after that he
started to get hazed brutally and you
know in that condition but just imagine
he'd never been north of the mason-dixon
line he never seen a profession a major
league baseball game until he played in
one uh he's scared he's 19 years old
uh and uh
or maybe 18 he didn't turn 19 until i
think they uh
that december and and uh and he's and
he's getting old how do you how do you
how do you
what do you how do you act towards your
mother when she shot your father i mean
do you provide her with
you know uh do you embrace her or do you
hate her you know it's a very hard and
confusing
time i i don't think you know
some people who paint cobb as a monster
and say well he's a monster because his
mother shot and killed his mother he
wasn't he wasn't a monster in the first
place and i think he you know he worked
his way through that he buried them
together for whatever that tells us
about what he thought uh and his mother
died
30 40 years later so uh
you know he buried them together he had
his childhood feelings about
their relationship and he you know he
put them in the same crypt
so
you know it's very unusual for a writer
to argue that it's you always arguing
your subject is extraordinary and
they're you and cobb was but i'm always
arguing that copy is just a normal human
being
uh i grew up a detroit tigers fan and it
was interesting because you hear the
stories that you were talking about from
the second group but you also hear the
stories from other tigers fans saying he
was a great player and all those things
so why do you think the detroit tigers
didn't do more to help his reputation
like you're trying to
you mean
since uh yeah
because don't forget now there's the
reputation of well some people said he
was a dirty player very sort of
within baseball kind of reputation that
not everyone subscribed to and then
there's the reputation that started in
in 1961 after he died the monster story
i
i can only guess what the tigers think
but i think
i think they probably i don't think they
believe it entirely or believe it now
they got that big nice statue
of him uh but they probably didn't want
to go there you know uh didn't want to
you know
glorify that uh too much but i'm only
guessing what other people are
are thinking is a powerful myth and
there were no counter myths
for a long time
thank you very much uh what did uh did
ty cobb have a second career what do you
do after baseball and what was his
reputation during those years well he
had kind of a
his his his as i say in the book the
first years of his life were like a rip
roaring yarn all kinds of things happen
good and bad and
um
after he retired his life
he didn't he never he got out of
baseball he never came back into
baseball maybe he should have in
retrospect he just golfed a lot
he got fat he started a drink
uh and uh it's it's not a it's not a
it's it's not a
happy story i think ultimately he he was
estranged from
two of his sons and in different ways
then he got
reconnected with one who
who died and those two sons both wound
up dying very young so he lived through
the two deaths of his sons
and he used to sit in his house in a
rock and yell and say my boys my boys
late at night uh he he eventually got
divorced from his wife remarried
uh got divorced from that woman he did
he didn't seem happy and he seemed to be
casting around and later in his his
career he assumed the role of kind of
the cranky old sage who was saying ah
it's not like it used to be you know
baseball he wrote an article for life
magazine that was famous it was all
about complaining about
you know baseball today you know that
kind of thing uh so he became that that
kind of a figure and um
it's a shame that his uh
his not but he was very well off
financially he he invested very smartly
in general motors and coca-cola stock
when he was uh a player
and he was financially independent and
secure and he urged sports writers to
buy coca-cola stock but in the
tradition of the press box they ignored
that advice you know and
they they never did a lot but uh so he
was he was financially well off but
didn't seem like a happy person in the
in the latter years
thank you very much for an enjoyable
talk so you mentioned that you wouldn't
go back to the original works and the
original text at the time and so my
question to you is in doing all that
research what is one cardinal example um
throughout ty cobb's life that shaped
his character both on and off the field
and projected into his later life after
his career in baseball thank you sir
one cardinal example of of what i found
by doing that
yes about his character maybe a snapshot
in his history that just really was a
turning point for his character in any
in any way i mentioned a couple of them
in my speech i mean is that quote about
the negro should be accepted
wholeheartedly and not grudgingly when i
came upon that i you know but even that
first scene in the in the dressing room
when i just saw a cobb acting normally
there's that word again and and uh um
you know the idea that he actually wrote
a letter to ban johnson the president of
the american league suggesting that
players dull their spikes with a file um
you know he he had uh
i don't you know the myth gets
embroidered he's he he becomes not just
uh anti-black he becomes anti-semitic in
the stories but his d he had a lot of
jewish friends and and and dealing with
jewish people i mean there were so many
so many things that were 180
degrees not that he but he never turned
into a saint he never turned into the
other kind of unreal person i mean there
were plenty
you know this
people fought more in those days men
they they resorted to fisticuffs more
that's true but even for that he was he
was known he had a reputation as someone
who would fight walter johnson the great
pitcher said he never started a fight
but boy if you said the you know if he
thought he said the wrong thing to him
you were down on the floor with him
rolling around you know uh he had a
great sense of uh
uh propriety and how maybe this was a
southern thing about how people should
you know have you ever had a feeling
like you go in a restaurant or hotel
well i'm the customer here you know you
shouldn't be
that that extension cobb of of who's
where in the social hierarchy and who in
each
interchange in a business or whatever
was was perhaps overly developed and and
that that led to a lot of fights so it
was the things i mentioned and uh like i
said there were more inconvenient truths
than convenient ones they were all over
the place these examples
thank you very much
you